en este vídeo lo que haremos es
ejercicios respecto a las sumatorias que
ya hemos logrado veamos hagamos números
grandes que tal 9.367 más vamos a
cambiar el color para que se vea más
padre 2.459
ustedes ya saben hacer esto sin embargo
lo vamos a hacer juntos para que vean
que poco a poco hemos ido avanzando y
cada vez harán números más grandes
empezaremos como siempre con la columna
del lado derecho que es la de las
unidades donde 7 + 9 es igual a 16 que
significa este 16 recuerden es como un
10 + 6 entonces tenemos una moneda de 10
vamos a hacer nuestra moneda grande de
10 pesos
y tenemos seis moneditas de un peso
considerando que únicamente tuviéramos
monedas de peso tendríamos entonces seis
monedas de un peso una moneda de diez
más seis monedas de peso son 16 ok
vayamos a nuestro ejercicio de regreso
este 16 ustedes ya saben lo colocaremos
aquí en la columna que estamos
trabajando y arrastraremos el siguiente
1 ahora 16 son siete más cinco son 12
cambiemos el color y tenemos el 2 y
arrastramos el 1 ven como tenemos aquí
nuestro 12 ahora 1 + 3 es igual a 4 4 4
es igual a 8 cambiamos el color y esta
vez sólo tenemos un dígito en la
respuesta por lo que aquí tendremos 0
pensemos que simplemente lo dejamos
vacío y nos vamos con los números
originales de la operación 9 2
11 colocaremos el 11 en otro color y
pondremos nuestro 1 y llevaremos
arrastraremos hacia arriba hacia la
siguiente columna el 1 que tenemos
en esta columna originalmente estaba
vacía sin embargo nosotros tenemos un
nuevo número arrastrando así es que 10 +
0 es igual a 1 bajaremos directamente
este número 1 ya que se sumó con ceros y
tendremos entonces 9.367 + 2.459 es
igual a 11 mil 826 que tal que hacemos
uno más grande que tal que nos vamos a
los millones ahora cuánto será 2
millones 349 mil 15
a eso le sumaremos
7 millones
365 1999 ok se ve más grande ya
conocemos los mecanismos nos iremos
columna por columna empezando por la
derecha y recorriendo nos hacia la
izquierda tomemos esta primera columna
59 es igual a 14 colocaremos el 4 y
arrastraremos el 114 ahora 1 + 12 más 9
11 colocaremos entonces con un color
distinto
nuestro primer uno
arrastraremos el 1 de las escenas
correspondientes 10 19 10
tenemos un 0 y recorreremos o
arrastraremos el 1 del 10 19 10 5 15
colocamos el 5 y arrastramos el 1 de la
siguiente columna 1 + 4 5 5 11 colocamos
el 1 y arrastramos la decena hacia la
siguiente columna arrancamos la
siguiente columna 1 34 más 37 así es que
en este caso sólo tenemos un dígito
dejaremos únicamente
el 7 por lo tanto tendremos 0 para
arrastrar a la siguiente columna sólo
contaremos los dos números originales
que teníamos 2 + 7 es igual a 9 así es
que ahora tenemos que 2 millones 349 mil
15 más 7 millones 365 mil 999 suman 9
millones 715 mil 14
para finalizar haremos un número todavía
mayor que tal irnos ya con números de
seis o siete ocho cifras cuánto será la
sumatoria entre los siguientes dos
números 15 millones 999 mil 100 1 más
6 millones
888 1999 este número si está súper súper
loco cree en poderlo hacer yo creo que
sí vamos a tomar exactamente el mismo
mecanismo que hemos utilizado en los
vídeos anteriores y en los ejemplos
anteriores para lograr esta sumatoria ok
recuerden siempre empezaremos del lado
derecho e iremos columna por columna
haciendo las sumatorias de un solo
dígito recorriendo nos hacia la
izquierda y con orden arrastrando los
números que así lo requiera cuando
nuestra respuesta tiene dos dígitos
empecemos 19 10 colocaremos el cero y
arrastramos el 11 + 9 10 colocaremos el
0 y volvemos a arrastrar
uno hacia el siguiente hacia la
siguiente columna 109 es igual a 10
entonces volvemos a colocar el 0 y
arrastramos el 1 hacia la siguiente
columna 1 + 9 son 10 + 8 18
colocaremos el 8 y arrastraremos el 1
hacia la siguiente columna 19 son 10 + 8
otra vez tenemos 18 colocaremos el 8 y
arrastraremos el 1 hacia la siguiente
columna 19 10 + 8 otra vez son 18
colocaremos el 8 y arrastraremos el 1
hacia la siguiente columna ahora tenemos
15 es igual a 6 6 6 son 12 colocaremos
el 2 y arrastraremos el 1 hacia la
siguiente columna esta columna es la
octava columna se dan cuenta ahora
tendremos uno más uno es igual a
y como por arte de magia nosotros ya
somos capaces de poder leer cuánto es 15
millones 999 mil 001 más 6 millones 888
1999 que nos da el total de 22 millones
888 mil unidades ustedes digan si son
gatos perros frutas manzanas ustedes lo
ponen esto no fue magia realmente es que
ustedes ya saben hacerlo y recuerden
iniciamos siempre del lado derecho con
las unidades y nos recorreremos columna
por columna hacia la izquierda hasta
completar la cantidad de cifras que esto
tenga 5 10 20 35